ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ดอกผู้หญิงคะเดี๋ยวครูเอกเพราะแช่ screen
ก่อนนะผู้หญิงสบายดีไหมแข็งแรงไหมแข็งแรง
แข็งแรงแข็งแรงผู้หญิงดูครูเอ๋คิดว่าครู
เอ๋แข็งแรงเหมือนกันคุณตอบเองคนเดียวเลย
นะคะนักเรียนผู้หญิงไม่ถามครูเอ๋ล่ะคะอ้า
ๆครูเอ๋สบายดีไหมคะแข็งแรงไหมแรง
ดีค่ะอย่างแรงค่ะแข็งแรงแล้วก็แชร์สกรีน
นะคะอ่ะถ้ากูเองแล้วผู้หญิงขอทำให้ครู
ใหญ่นะคะแล้วก็เอก -  Format  Bag เราได้
ไหมคะคู๋ลบได้ค่ะคุณเอ๋ชอบค้างไว้ใช่ไหม
ปิดไม่ตัวนกติดแล้วครับติน่าโอเค
ผู้หญิงคะหาคลิปที่แล้วน่ะครูหญิงพูดถึง
เดี๋ยวกูจะไม่พูดวันนี้เหรอคะ
มันเลอะติด
วันนี้วันอะไรคะวันเสาร์ค่ะวันนี้วัน
เสาร์วันเสาร์สีม่วงเนาะวันไหนค่ะวัน
เสาร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 4 ค่ะ
วันที่ 4 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มิถุนายน
เดือนมิถุนายนปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะ
ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะ
อีกแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้เวลา 1
ทุ่มห้าสิบสามนาทีค่ะครูให้เขียนได้อะไร
คะก็ไม่รู้
7:00 น
7:00  53 นาทีค่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋
07:53 นาทีนะคะล้างคืนแล้วร่างคือป่ะนอน
ตอนค่ะกลางคืนแล้วมันมืดมันมืด
มันมืดมันมืดมืดแบบนี้นะนาย
มือ
ไงค่ะมันมืดไปนอนค่ะมืดมืดออกไปข้างนอก
ไม่ไม่ดีค่ะครูเอ๋ต้องนอนทุก S ตื่นค่อย
กลับมาก่อนนะเก๋นอนแล้ว
วิ่งไม่ได้ไปนอนหมายถึงว่ามันมืดแล้วไม่
ออกจากบ้านค่ะอยู่บ้านอยู่บ้านนะหมวดหมู่
บ้านทรัพย์ด้าหัวใช้อยู่บ้านซักผ้าถูบ้าน
ซักผ้าไง
อ๋อใช่ๆไม่คุยดูเอ้ยกูเอมีใครคะมีคำถาม
อะไรคะครูเอ๋คลิปที่แล้วครูหญิงถามครูเอ๋
คลิปนี้ครูเอ๋ถามครูหญิงไงได้ค่ะครูเอ๋
ครูเอ๋อยากถามอะไรโอโห้อยากถามว่าคลิปที่
แล้วนะผู้หญิงมีมีอะไรนัทมีกะละมังอ่ะใช่
ไหมครูเห็นมีกาละมังมีมือ
ที่นี่มีเสื้อ
ค่ะเราก็ในกาละมังก็มีฟองเนาะค่ะมี
บ่อ
ๆมีปอ 2  2 เยอะๆฟองก็มีมือคนกำลังซักผ้า
อ.จะแนะผ้าเสื้อผ้ารับสัตว์ไม่ซักกับทั้ง
หมด
โอเค
ไม่มีผ้าผ้ามีพาแล้วก็ซักไงใช่ค่ะครูเอ๋
เอ๋คลิปที่แล้วมีรูปซักผ้าซักมือสากเลอ
แล้วก็มีอีกรูปนึงเป็นสี่เหลี่ยมค่ะ
แบบนี้แล้วก็มีอารมณ์เป็นฝาแล้วก็มีฟอง
ที่นี่แล้วก็มีเสื้ออ่านี่
มีเสื้อคน
ซักผ้าสักค่าเหมือนกันค่ะซักผ้าเนี่ยมี
ซักมือกับซักเครื่องไอเอซักมือดีซัก
เครื่อง
เมีย
กูอย่างนี้คำถามอะไรคะคำถามว่าเวลาซักผ้า
เนี่ยซักมือนะคะ a น่ะซักมือกับซัก
เครื่องนักฆ่าแบบไหน
สบาย
คู๋ไงๆๆค่ะซักเครื่อง B
สบายขอสักเครื่องแบบ B สบายค่าซักแบบใช้ a
น่ะใช้กะละมัง
แล้วก็ใช้มือ
สบายหรือลำบาก
ลำบากค่ะครูเอ๋ต้องตีฟองแล้วก็ซักๆมันก็
บิดแล้วก็จะซักสัตว์
เหนื่อยค่ะผู้หญิงเป็น EXO
ลำบากแต่ถ้าบีซักเครื่องผู้หญิงถือแล้วก็
เปิดแล้วก็เอาผ้าถ้าใส่แล้วก็ปิดแล้วก็กด
ปุ่ม
บอยผู้หญิงก็ไปนั่งดูทีวีทราย
อ้อมสบายเอาทำไมคุยชอบลำบากใจนางสาวแล้ว
ครูเอ๋แล้วนะคะครูเอกคิดว่าซักผ้าเนี่ย
ซักมือซักเครื่องอันไหนสบาย
แบบไหนสบาย a ชอบซักมือครูเอรู้สึกซักมือ
สบายซักมือลำบาก
ใช่ใช่มันคิดไม่เหมือนกัน
เพราะว่าบางคนบอกก็ใส่เครื่องเราก็ไปกลับ
มาก็ตาก
แต่คุยซักมือนะมันรู้สึก
ซักเสร็จแล้วสบายขอครูเอ๋เนี่ยไม่คิดว่า
ซักมือจะลำบากใช่ไหมไปคิดค่ะหาย
เรื่องลำบากต้องมาเช็ดเช็ดเครื่อง
Auto ใช่ๆๆ
ซักมือสบายซักเสร็จก็เช็ดๆวางกะละมัง
เสร็จแล้วเอา
คิดไม่เหมือนกันไปค่ะงั้นคลิปนี้คู่หญิง
คิดสบายโอเคลำบากโอเคลายค่ะมีมีมีคุยมี
รูปอ่ะโห
คนวิ่งเหรอใช่ๆอ่ะคนนี้น่ะคนทั้งหมดตรง
นี้ค่ะโอ้ผู้หญิงเห็นไหมคะมีกล้าม
วิ่งก็มีค่ะแล้วเวลาที่เค้าวิ่งผู้หญิงดู
ที่เขาวิ่งอ่ะผู้หญิงแต่ว่าเขาวิ่งแบบ
สบายๆ
หรือลำบาก
ผู้หญิงดูเขาในรูปนะครูหญิงคิดว่าสบายค่ะ
เขาวิ่งแบบสบายๆเลย
สบายสบายๆ
งูไม่ลำบากไม่ลำบากและถ้าครูหญิงวิ่งอ่ะ
สบาย
ลำบาก
ผู้หญิงก็เลยไม่วิ่งกูเอ๋แล้วซะกูเอวิ่ง
ลำบากมาก
กูเอ๋คะค่ะผู้หญิงผู้หญิงจะถามล่ะคะไม่
ใช่คุยจะบอกว่าไม่ต้องวิ่งแค่ผู้หญิงเดิน
พี่ก็คิดโอนลำบากค่ะเดินอันนี้ไม่ดีนะกัน
นะไม่ดีๆกับครูเอ๋นี่ไม่ดีนะคะอ่าแล้วครู
เอกจะถามอะไรว่าจะถามว่าครูหญิงคิดว่าคน
ที่มีอาชีพวิ่งเนี่ยอ้าวิ่งนะวันนี้แหละ
ที่ดูน่ะเขาวิ่งสบายสบาย
แต่ชาย
ก่อนวิ่งเก่งๆอ่ะเขาสบายหรือลำบาก
บ่าค่ะครูเอ๋เขาต้องวิ่งทุกวันลำบากงงแต่
พอวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งไปจนแข็งแรงก็วิ่งสบายสบาย
สบายนะคะๆค่ะ
ไปค่ะคู่หญิงชายคนนี้ค่ะเขามีอะไรอยู่ที่
ระหว่างแขนนั้นตรงนี้ตรงจั๊กกะแร้เนี่ย
ไม้เท้าค่ะเอา
กูเห็นจะถามผู้หญิงว่ากู้หญิงคิดว่าผู้
ชายคนนี้เนี่ยคิดว่าเขาวิ่งได้สบายๆไหมคะ
ครูหมอเขาเดินก็ลำบากแล้วค่ะคุณต้องวิ่ง
ก็
เขาเป็นอะไรคะเนี่ยเขาน่าจะเจ็บขานะน่าจะ
ขาข้างนี้ใช่ไหมหรือว่าเท้าร้านจะขาขายใน
ราคาไม่โอเคชายเขาเจ็บขาข้างนี้งั้นเดิน
ก็ลำบากไม่มีไม่สอนใต้วิ่งน่าจะลำบากมาก
ค่ะต้องวิ่งทั้ง 4 นะคะครูเอ๋
ถ้ามีหมามาเนี่ยโอ้เอ้โอ้โหลำบากมากๆใช่
วิ่งไม่ได้
กูเอมีอีกอย่างไม่รู้สวยๆให้ดูด้วยบางที
มันเป็นคนนะคะได้ค่ะรูปอะไรคะรูปต่อไป
ทะเลเหรอคะครูเอ๋ใช่อันนี้ประเทศไทยกำลัง
จะถามเลยว่าประเทศไทยหรือเปล่าก็ได้ค่ะมี
เกาะหนึ่งผู้มีเกาะเกาะเกาะเกาะมากๆแหง
แล้วครูเอ๋จะถามอะไรครูหญิงคะจะถามว่าตรง
นี้นะครูหญิงเป็นวิวนะคะถ้าหิวค่อยเนี่ย
อะไรนะ View  Point ณจุดชมวิวใช่ไหมคะคน
ไทยก็พูด View  Point จนเลยยเออจุดชมวิว
จุดชมวิวก็คือมายืนที่นี่
แล้วก็ถ่ายรูป
ก็จะได้รูปนี้
สวยค่ะอาครูเอกจะถามผู้หญิงว่าถ้าครูหญิง
นะนั่งเรือมาที่นี่
นะคะแล้วก็ขึ้นขึ้นขึ้นมา
ขึ้นมาที่จุดชมวิวตรงเนี้ยผู้หญิงหรือว่า
ไปแบบสบายๆหรือลำบาก
ผู้หญิงนะคะค่ะลำบากค่ะครูเอ๋ท้องใหม่
ต้องเดินเดินขึ้นเดินขึ้นนี่หนูเหนื่อย
ค่ะร้องแล้วก็ทางเดินก็ลำบากนะพี่เอ๋ดูสิ
ให้
ผู้หญิงรู้ไหมตอนนี้ดีกว่าเมื่อก่อนที่
ครูแอบไปนะตอนนี้แบบในรูปดีแล้วหรอคะจะ
บายก็ภัยแล้วหรอกูหญิงเวลาคู๋ไปที่นี่ไม่
มีเชือกไม่มีเสา kuai ต้องอยู่ตรงนี้ค่ะ
เดี๋ยวต้องแล้วก็ชุบตกไม่ตกตกไม่ตกโหตื่น
เต้นรถ
แต่ตอนนี้สบายกว่าเมื่อก่อนใช่แตะผู้หญิง
ไม่เคยเดินขึ้นก็คิดว่าลำบากใช่ไหมชายขับ
แล้วครูเอ๋คะครูเอกคิดว่าเดินจากเกาะ
เนี่ยขึ้นมาจุดชมวิวสบายหรือลำบากคะครู
เอ๋อ้าถ้าเมื่อก่อนและครูเห็นแบบนี้ครู
เอกคิดสบาย
ตอนนี้ครูเอ๋หัวเข่า
หัวเข่า
ไม่ดี
ดีขึ้นลำบากโคตรเซลล์เจ็บเชื่อจับนะกูเอ๋
อ่ะขึ้นน่ะโอเคค่ะมีเครื่องลงน่ะลำบาก
ยิ่งใช่เจ็บเจ็บหัวเข่าใช่ไหมคะขึ้นไม่
เป็นไรอ่ะลำบากพี่แบทเหนื่อย OK แป๊บลง
อันนี้ลำบาก
นักเรียนนะคะคิดว่าขึ้นไปจุดชมวิวนะคะ
เกาะตรงนี้เรียกว่าหมู่เกาะวัวตายอ่ะหมู่
เกาะอ่างทองค่ะถูกเกาะอ่างทองเนี่ยนะคะ
แล้วก็มีจุดชมวิวตรงนี้
ลำบากหรือสบายโต๊ะนักเรียนบอกสบายใช่
เพราะนักเรียนบางคนเคยมาแล้วก็ขึ้น
ชอบมากชอบเดินขึ้นใช่รถแม่กูเองอะไรนะมี
รบขึ้นจุดชมวิวไม่มี
ถ้าผู้หญิงคิดลำบากก็ข้างล่างไม่ต้องขึ้น
ได้เห็นวิวนี้ไงวิวสวยและก็ต้องลำบากโต๊ะ
อยากเห็นสวยๆ
ประมาณ 400 เมตรป่ะไม่น่าจะ 400 เมตรโอเค
อยู่นะสบายๆคุยสว่างได้ค่ะคิดสบายๆคือ
ต่อไป
โอ้วอันนี้กว่าค่ะ
อะไรเค้าครูเอ๋รูปนี้เนี่ยรูปนี้นะคะรูป
นี้อ่ะกูเองไม่สะอาดรูปมี 2 รูปมีรูปนี้
ที่เดียวกันนะคะสวนเป็นสวนต้นไม้คือสวน
ราชพฤกษ์นะค่ะอยู่ที่ประเทศไทยใช่ไหมคะ
ประเทศไทยเชียงใหม่นะคะผู้หญิงคิดว่าแบบ
นี้เดินสบายๆหรือลำบากสบาย
เดินสบายใช่ค่ะสบายแล้วถ้าไม่อยากเดินก็
มีแบบนี้ไม่มีอะไรคะมีรถลางนี้มีรถสบาย
หรือลำบากคะสบายมากค่ะครูเอ๋ไม่ต้องเดิน
นั่งแล้วก็มีคนขับรถให้เราดูวิวดูวิวสบาย
ค่ะครูเอ๋แล้วครูหญิงชอบแบบลำบากหรือสบาย
ผู้หญิงชอบสบาย
ตัวเองนะคะพี่เอ๋ชอบแบบลำบาก
จุดชมวิวสวยๆหรือชอบแบบสบาย
จริงๆครูเอ๋ชอบลำบากเข้าใจตั้งแต่ซักผ้า
แล้วค่ะ
อันนี้สนุกนักเรียนสนุกเสียใจเอ่อตอนนี้
เดินลง
แม่ไม่สบายลำบากตัวเองก็ขึ้นแล้วก็ไม่ลง
ไม่ได้ก็ไม่ได้ไม่ได้น้องนอนไว้ได้ผู้
หญิงรู้แล้ว
อะไรคะครูเอกขึ้นแล้วก็ลงก็ครูหญิงกูเอง
ว่ะไม่ได้
คิดว่าตายสั่งสองคนมันจะตกๆไม่ได้
เดินเดิน
เองโอเคจับเองขายค่ะลำบากไม่ไปไปอันนี้
สบายนะตอนนี้เราเจ็บเข่าแล้วก็ไปดูสบายๆ
ต่อไปค่ะผู้หญิงกูเองมีรูปให้ดูรูปนี้เขา
ทำอะไรกันอยู่เหรอคะครูเอ๋อ่าเขาเขาเขา
กำลังถอนต้นข้าวค่ะคะอันนี้คือต้นข้าวหรอ
คะอ่ะใช่ต้นข้าวเขาจะถอนแต่คู่เอ็มไม่มี
รูปต่อไปแล้วก็เอาไปปลูกค่ะชุบเขาเพลงให้
ใช่ค่ะเขาเป็นชาวนาใช่ค่ะ
ผู้หญิงชาวนาเนี่ยมีถอนต้นกล้าตัวนี้เขา
ได้กล้านะค่ะกล้าเสร็จแล้วเขาก็จะไปอีก
นานนึง
นะเค้าก็จะปลูกค่ะ
ปลูกแบบนี้
แต่ก็ข้าวโตโตๆเขาก็จะเกี่ยวข้าวไอ้คะหนู
ใช้อะไรเกี่ยวคะใช้อะไรเกี่ยวข้าวใช้
เคียวค่ะก็อย่ามาก็ได้นะมันมองเห็นโอเค
มองเห็นไหมเนี่ยมันถึงข้างๆสีขาวเทาๆก็
มองเห็นอ้ะใช้ตัวนี้ค่ะ
เคียวแล้วก็เกี่ยวค่ะอ่ะค่ะค่ะ
ใส่ใส่รองเท้าบูทๆใช่แล้วต้องมีหมวกอย่าง
นี้นะคะผู้หญิงมันร้อนแหม
แขนยาวเสื้อแขนยาวแล้วก็ใส่ถุงมือ
โห
มาจากครรภ์ค่ะนะคะ
บางทีฝนไม่ตก
โง่แล้วปลูกข้าวได้หรอฝนไม่ตกเข้าตายล่ะ
you ไม่มีน้ำค่ะ
ครูหญิงครูเอ๋ถามกูหญิงว่าอยากจะถามอะไร
คะว่า
ชาวนาชาวนาเนี่ย
เขาลำบากหรือสบาย
วิงคิดละกันนะถ้าผู้หญิงคิดว่าลำบากค่ะ
ครูเอ๋เอาไม่สบายนะไม่สบาย
อยู่
ยายค่ะแล้วก็ต้องก้ม
ปวดหลังหาเนี่ยค่ะเนี้ยกรม
ง่อมกลมจะต้มแล้วก็เคยนึกออมแล้วก็เงยโอ
ผู้หญิงเคยทำแบบนี้ปวดหลังค่ะอ๋อน้ำชาวนา
ลำบากใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะลำบากถ้าฝนไม่ตก
สบาย
ลำบากมาก
ไม่จบก็ไม่ต้องก้มห๊ะเห้ยไงสบายๆ
ผู้หญิงแต่เช้านะก็จะปลูกข้าวไม่ได้
ก็ไม่มีเงินถูกลำบากมากไม่มีข้าวกินก็
เพราะลำบากแค่ไหนผู้หญิงก็ลำบากด้วยซึ่ง
มีข้าวกินได้งั้นเราเนี่ยต้องขอบคุณชาวนา
ขอบคุณค่ะชาวนาขอบคุณค่ะค่ะเคียวค่ะ
ขอบคุณชาวนะค่ะ
ขอบคุณชาวนาที่ปลูกข้าวให้ครูหญิงให้ครู
เอ๋กินนะคะเพราะว่าเช้านะเนี่ยลำบากนะคะ
นักเรียนให้ลำบากมาก
ผู้หญิงคะสวยไหมสวยค่ะเหมือนครูหญิงเลยจะ
เอาเป็นซุปเปอร์โมเดลเอาเป็นแบบใช่ไหมคะ
ผู้เองเป็นนางแบบแต่คนไทยก็พูด Super
Model นะใช่เขาให้กับผู้ Super  Model
เป็นนางแบบนะคะนางแบบบุกผู้หญิงคิดว่าคน
ที่เป็นนางแบบเนี่ยทำงานสบายหรือจะลำบาก
เขาผู้หญิงใส่ชุดสวยๆเวลาทํางาน
ผู้หญิงที่แล้วกันจะเอาตัวผู้หญิงนะคะค่ะ
ลำบากค่ะครูเอ๋ทำไมคะผู้หญิงนี่ชาวนา
เนี่ยชาวนาทำงานมีพระอาทิตย์
ร้อนๆต้มนายกรมไง
นางแบบเนี้ยใส่ชุดสวยๆมีมีนวดตัวมีจุดๆ
แล้วก็เดินเดินเดินเดิน
ทำไมปากกินนิดหน่อย
ไม่อยากกิน KFC ออกไม่ได้อยากกินอ่ากฎก็
เปิ้ลเบอร์เกอร์ไม่ได้กินได้นิดหน่อยผู้
หญิงกินแอปเปิ้ลได้
กินเยอะก็ไม่ได้ไงไม่แล้วก็ทุกวันทุกวัน
เนี่ยต้องแก้กำลังกายไปวิ่งควายนี้คิดผู้
หญิงคิดลำบากค่ะครูเอ๋ก็ลำบากใช่ไหมแล้ว
เราพูดอ้ะครูเอกคิดว่าเป็นนางแบบเนี่ย
ลำบากหรือสบายคะโอ๊ยครูเอ๋ชอบกินโอเคคิด
ว่าสบายเอกชอบนอนค่ะครูเอ๋
ชอบชอบอะไรคะอ่านหนังสือครูเอ๋ชอบดูชอบ
ชอบเดินไหมไม่ชอบออกกำลังกายไหมไปวิ่ง
ว่ายน้ำไปชอบช๊อปเมคอัพมั้ยทาปากเขียน
คิ้วชอบถ่ายรูปไหม
ออกถ่ายรูปครูพี่เก๋ไปท็อปส์อุ้ย Action
ไม่เป็น
กูเอกก็เลยคิดว่าเป็นนางแบบเนี่ยสบายมั้ย
คะลำบากค่ะสำหรับผู้เอกคิดนะเพราะนางแบบ
คิดเหมือนครูหญิงกินได้นิดหน่อยแล้วก็
ต้องวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งว่ายน้ำว่ายน้ำ
ต้อยขัดผิวสวยๆด้วยไงที่กูเอบอกอ่ะแล้วก็
ต้องอะไรนะต้องอะไรคะเวลาเดินใช่มั้ย
เดี๋ยวกูเอกจะมีอะไรไหมถึงมีหนังสือไหมคะ
มีหนังสือวางที่หัวไหมคะเพื่อน
คอมพิวเตอร์ก่อนนะคะ
โอเค
ไม่ได้ค่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋นั้นไม่ได้เป็นมาร์ช
ชิ่งแบนนะคะครูเอ๋
ยังไม่ได้นางแบบ screw เอ๋และไอ้ต้นซ้าย
ขวา
มีสายค่ะครูเอ๋
เว้นดอกมาเป็นครูค่ะกลับมาเป็นครู
โอ้ยโอ๊ยเลยนะคะเป็นนางแบบสำหรับครูเอ๋
น่ารำบากสำหรับครูหญิงแม่ลำบากได้ปาก
สำหรับนางแบบก็ลำบากนะเขาชอบเขาก็ต้อง
โอเคใช่ไหมคะให้จน 1 วันเก่งเก่งแล้วก็
สบายนะคะๆค่ะ
โอเคต่อไปเป็น
ครู
เป็นครูสบายหรือลำบากคะผู้หญิงเป็นครูหรอ
ครูโรงเรียนท้ายโอ้โหครูโรงเรียนไทยลำบาก
ค่ะครูเอ๋เป็นยังไงเหนื่อย
เหนื่อยมากต้องสอนเด็กๆต้องเขียนหนังสือ
แต่ไม่มีเวลากินไม่มีเวลานอน
ครูโรงเรียนไทยลำบากลำบากรู้แบบผู้หญิง
กับผู้เหล่ำบากไหมคะ
ก็ไม่สบายนะไม่พูด
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
[เพลง]
นักเรียนคิดว่าครูแบบครูหญิงกับครูเอ๋เอ๋
ลำบากไหมคะนักเรียนบอกได้นะ
หรือว่าไปอย่าลำบากนะคะลำบากไหมครูเอ๋ก็
คิดว่าครูโรงเรียนไทยลำบากใช่ไหมคะให้
เพราะว่ามีเด็กๆน่ะเด็กๆนะโอ้นักเรียน
เนี่ย
มีนักเรียน
นักเรียนเนี่ยหนูบางที
30-40 คนฮู้ตอนครูหญิงผู้หญิงห้าสิบคน
เลยนะคะครูเอ๋เฉพาะนะอีกหนึ่งห้องช้าใช่
แต่ครูต้องสอนกี่ห้อง
6 ของลูกใช้ค่ะงอกก็คูณ
ลำบากนั้นลำบากลำบากใจค่ะแล้วก็เด็กๆเยอะ
ไงอ่ะครูต้องดูเยอะ
ผู้หญิงแล้วนักเรียนราคาสบายหรือลำบาก
นักเรียนไทยในกรุงเทพฯใช่ไหมคะหรือว่านัก
เรียนแบบในรูปเอากรุงเทพฯก่อนกรุงเทพฯถ้า
นักเรียนที่กรุงเทพลำบากค่ะครูเอ๋ทำไม
เรียนคุกวันวันจันทร์วันอังคารวันพุธวัน
พฤหัสบดีวันศุกร์วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์เรียน
นักเรียนภาคเสาร์ใหญ่ๆๆ
ต่อไปค่ะแล้วก็ขึ้นรถใช่ไหมรถเมล์
มีรถรักรถเมล์
แล้วก็มีคนคนคนมากๆลำบาก
ลำบากและหน้านักเรียนในรูปราคาสบายหรือ
ลำบากถ้าเอาเป็นแบบผู้หญิงคิดสบายค่ะ
เมื่อก่อนครูหญิงก็เรียนแบบเด็กสบาย
วิ่งเล่นเรียนหน่อย
นักเรียนคิดว่าเด็กๆที่ที่ต่างจังหวัดนะ
คะเราก็ปลูกผักกินเองสบายหรือลำบากนะคะ
บ้านก็ชอบก็บอกสบายไม่ไม่ต้องขึ้นรถเมล์
แต่ว่าบางคนบอกก่อนเดินเดินเดินเดินไปโรง
เรียนลำบาก
ครูปลูกผักตัวมันเอง
ลำบากนะคะค่ะแล้วแต่บางคนคิดลำบากแบตหมด
กับครูเอ๋เวลาเด็กๆก็แบบนี้จ่ายผู้หญิง
คิดเก่งคิดไม่ต้องเรียนเหมือนเลขเหมือน
รูปคุณครูสอนแนวค่ะอันนี้ใช่มั้ยเนี่ยคุณ
ครูสอนเลขถ้าเรียนเลข
ลำบากค่ะปลูกผัดสบายปลูกผักสบาย
บางทีนักเรียนบ่ออกหักลำบาก
เรียนสบายครูแล้ว
ครูลำบากนักเรียนสบายไม่รู้
ๆคิดอะไรก็โอเคนะคะได้ค่ะจะได้อีก 1 รูป
ค่ะอุ้ยได้ 1 และข้อ 2 ไม่ได้หรอคะได้ค่ะ
2 ก็ได้ค่ะพี่ใจดีผู้หญิงคิดว่าเด็กคน
นี้สบายหรือลำบากค่ะผู้เหมือนกันนะคะถ้า
เอาเด็กคนนี้ใช่ไหมเด็ดคนนี้
ลำบากค่ะครูเอ๋เด็กกำลังทำอะไรคะขนาบน้ำ
อันนี้เป็นไม้คาน
แล้วก็ถังน้ำเด็กหาบน้ำอันนี้ลำบากเนาะ
ลำบากชัดเจ็บให้กูเอกก็คิดว่าลำบากนะคะ
ผู้หญิงไม่ได้นักเรียนโอเคอันสุดท้ายสุด
ท้ายจริงๆอย่างมีเยอะนะมีอะไรอีกค่ะครู
เอ๋ท้ายตัวเองมีบ้านให้เลือกหมู
บ้านทรงไทยค่ะ
อพาร์ทเม้นท์คอนโด Flash อะไรก็ได้นะคะ
ค่ะแล้วก็บ้านเดี่ยวบ้านตึกแล้วเนี่ย
ครูหญิงคิดว่า
บ้านแบบไหนอยู่แล้วสบาย
หญิงใช่ไหมไปมีเฮบ้านทรงไทย B  Condo
Apartment  8  4 บ้านตึก
4 ค่ะบ้านตึก phrase ใช่ไหมคะอ่าโอเคแค่
นี้อ่ะ
อันนี้จ๊ะ
ผู้หญิงบอกสบายดีไหมคะอ้าบายค่ะแล้วครู
เอ๋นะคะครูเอกคิดว่าบ้านแบบไหนครูเอ๋อยู่
แล้วสบาย
ครูเอกก็ชอบซีนะคะแล้วพี่คะใช่ชอบ 4 ว่า
มีที่ดินปลูกต้นไม้ด้วยเอาแต่ๆสำหรับผู้
เอกก็คิดซีก็ลำบากนะมันอย่างมันยาออกอะไร
อ่ะผู้หญิงไม่ทำ
กูเอกก็เลยบอกพูดหรือ
จริงอยู่อยู่เป็นห้องแบบคอนโดก็เกือบผู้
ชายมันร้อน
กลับบ้านไทยน่ะผู้หญิงไม่ชอบเหรอคะใหญ่
ค่ะครูหญิงนอนไม่ได้ค่ะลำบากมากคุณแม่ผู้
หญิงชอบมากนะคุณแม่อยู่บ้านบ้านบ้านไทย
ผู้หญิงอยู่สิค่ะใกล้ๆกันโอเคปีให้คุณแม่
อยู่กับแมวไปเลยค่ะเก๋ก็ไม่ชอบบ้านบ้าน
ไทยแบบนี้วิ่งคิดคูเอกชอบนะเนี่ยทำไมไม่
เวลาเทปอ่ะค่ะอ๋อ
มันลำบากลำบากมากขณะขาดเหนื่อยค่ะนั้น
เรียนอ่ะแบบ 4 สบายกว่านะคะถ่ายตอนเด็กๆ
ผิงเรียนโรงเรียนเป็นไม้แบบบ้าน Who  6
ค่ะต้องทำอะไรนะขี้ผึ้งเหรอแว็กซ์นัก
เรียนรู้เหนื่อยค่ะเหนื่อยก็นักเรียนอัน
นี้สวยหมอลำบากเปล่าถ้าไม่ทำโอไม่สวย
มายคราย
โอเคค่ะหมดเวลาใช่ไหมคะอะไรค่ะนักเรียนก็
คิดว่าบ้านแบบไหนลำบากสบายบอกคอมเมนท์ได้
นะคะแล้วนักเรียนก็คิดว่าอาชีพอะไรที่ครู
ให้ดูเนี่ยอะไรลำบากอะไรสบายคิดไม่เหมือน
ครูโอเคนะคะโอเคได้ค่ะเข้าใจลำบากเข้าใจ
สบายใจแล้วค่ะแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้ครูหญิงกับ
กูเอกกำลังจะไป
S  of ไปลำบากลำบากให้ไปล้างจานลำบากใจ
ค่ะน้องเดี๋ยวเราเจอกันใหม่ในวีดีโอหน้า
นะคะสวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบาย